i don't know if you heard uh alok sharma
earlier on but he seemed rather
frustrated by the run up to uh cop 26
and the the fact that uh we don't really
seem to be sure what's going to come out
of this how helpful are you
i met 500 plus delegates at
some pancreas yesterday
who were going to cop and lots of young
people and they were so enthusiastic and
so optimistic um and so positive i can't
help that rubbing off on me
um
but then the politician in me stops and
we look and we see
you know we had a commitment in paris to
keep to 1.5 so we have this ambition but
we see we don't seem to have the plans
the backfill you know how are we
actually going to get there and what we
need at the end of this cop meeting is
for countries to have plans on the table
that we can look at that we can
scrutinize we can hold them to account
and we can say okay the amount of carbon
your country is producing
and collectively with all the other
countries in the world will not take us
above 1.5 and we're such a long way from
that
mr barroso was uh rather skeptical about
the reasons given by the chinese
president and russian prison for not
showing up um
are you equally skeptical and do you
think it matters
well all that matters in the end is that
each country has a plan to get down to
net zero in a timely way
um you know getting there by 2060 is
probably is too late but i think as
important as when you get to net zero
is how much carbon you're producing on
your way down
and you know many countries seem to have
committed to getting to net zero but we
don't really have the plans from them as
to how it is that they're going to get
there
and that's as important as anything else
so whether people pitch up or whether
people don't pitch up i mean this is not
a kind of
i don't know
you know this is not just a sort of you
know a lap of honor for for countries
going there needs to be serious work
and my concern i if i'm being really
honest and brutal about this is that
quite often before these summits happen
a great deal of hard work has been done
and you know countries have got quite a
long way to the agreement before you get
the final
agreement at the meeting itself and
my concern is that there's still so much
work to be done at glasgow that uh
you know that a particular leader
turning up or not is not by itself going
to make a difference
the united nations says uh that uh on
current trends we are not going to make
it to 1.5 in fact they talk a bit more
about two plus and maybe even 2.7
degrees um
what would the
labour government have done that the
current government has not done
okay
right the first thing we would have done
was that we would have as i've already
alluded to we would need to be making
sure that we were doing really serious
negotiations for a much longer period
than this government has done and had
much more
much more grip we would have had to
focus on it much more than we have done
um i know that alex sharma has done his
best but frankly it is a failure of our
ability to be able to bring countries
together that we haven't got more
agreement before now number one number
two we would be showing leadership by
example we would not be having a budget
in which we were suddenly cutting taxes
on internal flights you know we would
not be cutting back on the amount of
money that was available to invest in
the developed world because we've cut
back 0.7 and so there is not the money
going into the developed world in the
way that we need to we need to be
putting money into the developed world
in order to help them to get to net zero
and also to help protect them against
the effects of climate change which is
already happening what else would we be
doing so we'll be properly negotiating
we'll be leading by example we will be
looking after the most vulnerable we
will be making sure that the action made
by this government would have we would
look to to to
measure action by this government
against the effect that it was having on
on on biodiversity what were we doing in
my own brief i have to say just looking
at what i would be doing we have this
30 years ago our government as one of
many signed up to an investment charter
on energy and this investment charter
was from another age but essentially
it's being used by energy companies to
challenge sovereign nations who are
doing their best to get to net zero so
we're seeing countries like italy like
the netherlands you have a policy to to
get rid of carbon from there from the
atmosphere of being challenged by coal
companies saying you're not allowed to
undermine our profits
now so what can i do about it is
changing and well that charting is
changing and some countries are saying
that they want to change it but britain
is still sitting on the fence so just
from my own brief it just shows that we
are not really leading by example
um the rich country said uh at paris
that what they try to do is to put
together a fund of 100 billion i talked
a little earlier in this program to
tinastedu from the marshall islands who
was very polite about it but looked
pretty
hacked off about the fact that almost
none of that i mean a very small amount
of that money seems to have actually
been pledged um how much would we should
we be putting into that
we should be putting in the amount that
we promised i mean nations turned up at
paris made pledges they get the fanfare
they get the headlines and then the
money doesn't isn't available it's the
same as you know developing countries
are pretty hacked off when it comes to
vaccines when we make all these promises
to be to be ensuring that they get
access to vaccines and we still haven't
done that either you know we're not
going to be
even on the plans now as to has changed
the vaccines are not going to be
available to the develo developing world
until way into next year this is not
good enough
brutally put i mean
it is not your habit to agree on
anything with the prime minister but he
has been rather gloomy this week um
brutally put um
you're sort of in the same camp as he is
aren't you that you think that we are
quite a long way from getting an
agreement that we need
i would really like to see the prime
minister use such statesmanship as he
has
um to put all effort into glasgow
it is not all lost
but we really do need to be serious
about it this is not a giant photo
opportunity we cannot spend our time
green washing nations we have to be
truthful about how big a problem this is
how far we have to go
and we have to make sure that there is
some serious commitments made not just
by us but by other countries and boris
johnson has to summon up all
statesmanship as he has to be able to
fulfill the role of leadership which
britain needs to be doing at this time